good afternoon
good afternoon today as you have figured
out the state made a motion to nollie
cross the charges against Jesse Smollett
and to seal the record in this case we
believe that it was the correct result
in this case we're very happy for this
result and we are very anxious for Jesse
to get on with his career and his life
and to move forward I'll take any
questions
this is not there is no deference
occasion when was to nollie price which
is Jesse voluntarily agreed to the
forfeiture of the bond we believe to the
city of Chicago but we don't know there
is no deal the state dismissed the
charges we have nothing to say to the
police department except to investigate
charges and not try their cases in the
press but to allow matters to be
investigated allow the state to
investigate and to bring charges and not
to jump ahead and utilize the press to
convict people before they are tried in
a court of law
[Music]
the next question
I have no idea what occurred in this
case and why it occurred I can just say
that things seem to spiral somewhat out
of control
we've gotten to a result that is the
right result in this case and we're
happy for them I have no idea
plenty of people forfeit their bond in
situations like this
jesse is and as if you were in the
courtroom heard the prosecutors say and
we made sure that the prosecution knew
he is someone who has dedicated his life
to public service since he was 15 years
old he he has taken the city of Chicago
as his home he has volunteered in a
variety of ways he is a good solid
citizen of the city of Chicago that was
the comment made by the prosecutor today
and the undara brothers said more than
once that the $3500 check they received
was for exactly what Jesse said it was
for nutrition and training they were his
trainers that statement was not I don't
know where the superintendent got that
information I was not privy to it and
quite frankly have not seen that footage
so I have no idea where that came from
which is why you should allow
investigation and allow the state to
investigate a charge before you go to
the press
I have no idea you know I don't have
information that the state would have as
to why they brought these charges I
don't know you'd have to ask the state
the two men who attacked him have
indicated that they attacked him so we
already know who attacked him those
brothers have well that's up to the
state well the two brothers have said
that they attacked him so you know we
don't want to try them in the press any
more than he wanted to be tried as that
decision was made so that he could go on
with his life and get this over with and
not have to fight and not have to
continue with all of the disruption to
his career he is he is a very sweet
individual who has for a lifetime
dedicated himself to his career to the
public to children to the movement in
the LGBTQIA community and this was a
disruption to that he wants to get back
to it I'll allow you to hear from him
briefly and then we're gone everybody I
just made a couple notes first of all I
want to thank my family my friends the
incredible people of Chicago and all
over the country in the world who have
prayed for me who have supported me
who've shown me so much love no one will
ever know how much that has meant to me
and I will forever be grateful
I want you to know that not for a moment
was it in vain
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother son if I was capable of
one drop of what I was accused of this
has been an incredibly difficult time
honestly one of the worst of my entire
life
but I'm a man of faith and I'm a man
that has knowledge of my history and I
would not bring my family our lives or
the movement through a fire like this I
just wouldn't so I want to thank my
legal counsel from the bottom of my
heart
and I would also like to thank the state
of Illinois for attempting to do what's
right
now I'd like nothing more than to just
get back to work and move on with my
life
but make no mistakes I will always
continue to fight for the justice
equality and betterment of marginalized
people everywhere you just get back to
work and move on with my faith and thank
you too god bless y'all thank you very
much
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]